[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen ganz ganz schnell
das rezept und zwar eine ich sag jetzt
mal eine asiatische pfanne mit hähnchen
und brokkoli bitte tötet mich nicht wenn
sich original asiatisch ich war halt
noch nie
ich war nie in japan und in china ich
kann nur das machen was ich heute kennen
von der asia restaurants hier
okay ich war in hongkong schon und und
doch nicht mehr wisse was davon
berichten ja hauptsache es schmeckt und
ich habe hier einfach so ein paar
zutaten dabei wie soja sauce und
fischsauce die aber auch ganz gut
austauschen könnt ich zeige euch mal die
zutaten dafür brauche ich zwei teelöffel
sesamöl 600 gramm hähnchenbrustfilet das
habe ich jetzt bereits kleingeschnitten
500 gramm brokkoli bereits in röschen
geteilt ein stück ingwer 3
knoblauchzehen sechs frühlingszwiebeln
und für die soße habe ich jetzt hier
noch zutaten und zwar zwei teelöffel
reichlich zwei esslöffel fischsauce vier
esslöffel sojasauce einen teelöffel
stärke 300 milliliter wasser und zwei
esslöffel sesam und salz und pfeffer
also jetzt ihr jetzt ein paar exotische
zutaten bei der soße dabei statt
sojasauce könnt ihr natürlich auch was
anderes nehmen aber ich finde sojasauce
bringt natürlich die würze hier mit rein
den reis es ich könnt ihr zum beispiel
austausch mit weißweinessig und die
frisch so viel und die fischsauce könnt
ihr auch gerne weglassen
aber um das ganze so ein bisschen
asiatisch zu machen finde ich die
zutaten schon wichtig und mittlerweile
bekommt man die auch echt überall also
fast jeder supermarkt hatten asia ecke
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein schälchen
reis und zwar wollte ich eigentlich
jasmin reis demokrat hat einfach und
päckchen gekauft wo jetzt china reist
draufstand jasmin reis ist es einfach
ein bisschen aromatischer und ich mache
gleich die quelle reis methode
das heißt ich habe jetzt hier ein und
halb gläser reis und dann kommen drei
gläser wasser dazu aber der reis wird
vorher einmal kurz abgewaschen unter
klarem wasser
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt direkt das kalte wasser
mit dazu also die doppelte menge einfach
und ich mag es gerne wenn der reis auch
ein bisschen salz hat viele würzen den
coups hervorgeht natürlich auch ein
bisschen sah es noch rein und jetzt
lasse ich den reis aufbrauchen und gibt
dann den deckel drauf und dann stelle
ich die hitze herunter und lass einfach
das wasser auf 10 einziehen
1 10 einziehen aufsaugen auch sorgen
jetzt geht es weiter jetzt eben der
internet blog oder einfach einem großen
topf so wie ich habe habe ihr wissen
wollt ob kaka und jetzt das sesamöl
reihe und wie gesagt könnt ihr das zum
beispiel auch gerne durch sonnenblumenöl
ersetzen so billiger murat da ist so
wahrscheinlich habe begriffen dass die
kosten 99 kg zeigen die großen flächen
ist ich habe schweißausbrüche gekriegt
hat ein schwabe ja nimmt zu ruhig
sollten kein problem weil es wird das öl
ein bisschen erhitzt und dann kann ich
da nämlich das fleisch drin antraten
und jetzt kommen da die hähnchenbrust
streifen rain und werden rundherum
angebraten bitte schön braun sind
ich mache es nicht alle auf einmal rein
sondern das gesamte auf zwei positionen
und die zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
nutzen um schon mal die
frühlingszwiebeln klein zu schneiden
wird irgendwann zu stellen und zu
schneiden und auf die knoblauchzehen
fein zu hacken
und dann irgendwann könnt ihr übrigens
ganz einfach mit einem löffel schälen
was einfach die schale so ein bisschen
ableiten
[Musik]
gerade ich die zweite portion an und wir
noch mal ein bisschen öl braucht gibt
einfach noch ein bisschen was dazu
jetzt kommt das gesamte fleisch wieder
hier rein dann gebe ich sie gesehen und
dann irgendwann dazu und braten sie
soetwas zwei bis drei minuten mit an und
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
die zutaten für die soße verrühren und
zwar gebe ich jetzt hier in eine
schüssel das wasser die stärke zum
binden
plattling
da kommt das restliche wasser betreiben
und auch die restlichen zutaten also
reis es sich diebisch soße sojasauce
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die soße hier direkt rein
seinem kurz aufkochen lassen jetzt
einmal richtig schön di resta rom mit
dabei jetzt kommt da der brokkoli noch
dazu und die hälfte der
frühlingszwiebeln den rest bereich auch
für die deko jetzt könnt ihr an der
stelle auch gerne schon mal abschmecken
mit salz und pfeffer und da kommt jetzt
ein deckel drauf ich stelle die hitze
herunter und dann kam das ganze ein
bisschen gar ziehen etwa fünf minuten
und dann ist das hähnchen perfekter
populis noch bissfest der reise song
fertig und dann kommen nämlich gleich
anrichten
und wenn ihr merkt so wie ich das hier
noch ein bisschen wasser benötigt dann
gebt einfach jetzt noch ein bisschen was
dazu
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich anrichten das für den
kreis benutze ich jetzt ein schälchen
also jasmin reis mit viel viel besser
als den jetzt gerade hier haben aber
morath der schweiz frankreich musste
mich dass das bild nicht gut ist da
kommt dass hier zumindest der teil
ich weiß aber kimi ist wirklich schmeckt
ich war ja schon in hongkong
ja ich weiß hat er dann zwei wochen lang
durchfall bei deinem freund william ja
und es lustig war wie die mein freund
william war ja letzte woche bei mir und
ich habe in einem zimmer essen
ausgeführt und wollte mal auch zeigen
mit deutsches essen ist und damit in
frankfurt
chili ja ins wagner und jemand aus
frankfurt konnte ist wagners so typisch
richtig frankfurter essen ist und dann
saßen am tisch da kamen die habe ich
gesagt bitte etwas richtig ekliges
richtig ähnliches werde ich möchte ihnen
heimzahlen was ich immer nicht wieder
essen muss ohne hat er dann gesagt ja
kommen aber wohl frankfurter
schlachtplatte also morath darf jetzt
probieren ich habe das ganze ist noch
bis er mit chili und sesam serviert und
auch ein und schiebe ich so asiatisches
nicht in asien anders als bei uns aber
ich bin europäer sind hat andere ist ein
anderes probiert er zuerst seinen billig
reiße ich glaube es über alles kann
schon ein bisschen sambal olek geben
bitte ja jetzt drängt alles mit zambrano
ja ich liebe es einfach ich mag
geschafft und ich mag scharfe sachen
verpackt ja
doch ich kenne aufstieg hinter sich hat
das team kaputt gemacht ganz aber egal
eine kleine öffnung es geht bestimmt so
ich mag es gemeinsam zum fotografieren
das wissen sie ja sie muss einfach
gerade zerstört darf ich jetzt ein
bisschen scharf aber er schmeckt super
wirklich der kanzlerin versagen war oleg
geowissenschaft und schön frisch
schnelles rezept also ich hab jetzt
nicht länger als 20 minuten gebraucht
und man kann es natürlich auch abwandeln
ich würde vielleicht noch champignons
dazu geben aber ich bin halt auch
champignons plan
ich kenne menschen die mögen keine nicht
wie gesagt mir ums abgewandelt sagt
artig cool oder ehrlich glücklich
ja und ich glaube die kinder hörten sie
mögen deswegen haben ja auch kein
schiller jetzt ins essen rein sondern
jeder keiner zugeben
und weil sie das rezept nachkochen
möchte dann schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei aufs aliens - blog der firma
gespannt auf eure variation
ich bin voll gut darin den murat einfach
zu ignorieren und einfach weiterzureden
ich habe das erst zehn jahre alt gibt
und ich glaube ich kann das echt ganz
gut ohne mich aus dem takt bringen zu
lassen
also murat dir noch einen guten appetit
euch viel spaß und nach macht und auch
und guten appetit und bei uns gibt es
auch mittagessen und abendessen und ich
würde mein geld ausgeben
[Musik]